foreign
foreign
practice
everything
all right
foreign
no
yes
foreign
one hundred and ninety fifth meeting of
the Security Council is called to order
the provisional agenda for this meeting
is maintenance of peace and security of
Ukraine
the agenda is adopted
in accordance with rule 37 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
I invite the representatives of Estonia
Poland Slovakia and Ukraine to
participate in this meeting
it is so decided
in accordance we wrote 39 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
I invite Miss Rosemary decalu under
Secretary General for political and
peace building affairs to participate in
this meeting
it is so decided
in accordance with wrote 39 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
I also invite his Excellency Mr Olaf's
cork head of the delegation of the
European Union to the United Nations to
participate in this meeting
it is so decided
the security Council will now begin his
consideration of item 2 of the agenda
I now give the floor to miss Rosemary
decalu
Mr President
in the past few days ukrainians have
been subjected to some of the most
intense bombardments of the
nine-month-old War Russian missiles and
drones have rained down on Kiev with
Goliath Jersey
voltava and elsewhere destroying or
damaging homes and severely disrupting
critical services
the impact of such attacks can only
worsen during the coming winter months
as of 14 November the office of the High
Commissioner for human rights has
recorded sixteen thousand six hundred
thirty one civilian casualties six
thousand fifteen five hundred fifty
Seven Persons killed and 10 074 injured
since the start of the full-scale
invasion of Ukraine
the recent barrages Will alas add to the
horrific toll the war has already taken
I must say it again attacks targeting
civilians and civilian infrastructure
are prohibited under International
humanitarian law
the military Dynamics on the ground
continue to evolve in the past week the
city of her son returned to Ukrainian
government control
heavy battles also continue in Donetsk
and luhansk regions
indeed there is no end in sight to the
war
as long as it continues the risks of
potentially catastrophic spillover
remain all too real
yesterday's incident in Poland near the
Ukrainian border was a frightening
reminder of the absolute need to prevent
any further escalation
I wish to join the Secretary General in
extending condolences to the families of
the two polish citizens killed in the
incident
Mr President the ongoing bombardment of
Ukraine has already damaged an estimated
40 percent of the country's power
generation capacity
Kiev has been hit hardest
most parts of the capital are now
without electricity for 12 hours a day
as the Ukrainian government focuses on
repairing damaged infrastructure
the United Nations has made it a
priority to ensure that most vulnerable
the most vulnerable receive winter
supplies and services
more than 185 000 people have already
received essential basic winter supplies
humanitarian partners are setting up
heating points near the front lines some
525 generators were provided or are
being distributed to Priority
institutions including hospitals
Collective centers and Clinics
humanitarian access has resumed in the
areas back under Ukrainian government
control including in her son
however it is still extremely difficult
to reach people in need in areas of the
east and south under the control of the
Russian military and across the front
line
contamination particularly in areas
close to the front are where control has
recently shifted are putting more lives
at risk impeding the movement of
civilians and hampering humanitarian
efforts
I remind the parties that International
humanitarian law requires them to
facilitate rapid and unimpeded passage
of humanitarian relief for all civilians
in need
Mr President the allegations of
atrocities and human rights violations
in Ukraine during this war are extensive
today I'd like to highlight grave
concerns about the rights Safety and
Security of the youngest ukrainians
over 400 children have been killed
and many more have been injured lost
their family members have been forced to
leave their homes
according to the government portal
children of War
279 children were considered missing as
of 12 November
there are also disturbing reports of
forced transfers of children including
of some under institutionalized care to
Russian occupied territory or to the
Russian Federation
ohchr has documented several individual
cases including of unaccompanied
children that appear to amount to
deportations to the Russian Federation
in violation of international
humanitarian law
ohchr also continues to document other
types of human rights violations
including 57 verified cases of
conflict-related sexual violence
48 of these cases are attributable to
Russian armed forces and Affiliated
groups nine are attributable to
Ukrainian armed forces and law
enforcement authorities
the independent International Commission
of inquiry on Ukraine continues its work
towards accountability for alleged
violations and abuses of Human Rights
and violations of international
humanitarian law with ongoing
investigations in and out of Ukraine
the Commissioners are planning another
visit to Ukraine before the end of the
year
another issue of concern is the
conditions of prisoners of War
I welcome the continued prisoner
exchanges between Russia and Ukraine
including most recently on 11 November
I encourage the sides to continue
releasing pows
I call on the parties to ensure Humane
treatment of prisoners of war in line
with their obligations under
international law in particular the
third Geneva Convention
I also call on the Russian Federation to
Grant ohchr in icrc on impeded access to
detainees
to president the extension of the Black
Sea grain initiative remains vital to
help avert a food crisis for millions of
people
more than 10 million metric tons of
foodstuffs have now been moved under the
initiative reaching or on their way to
some 40 countries
the impact of the initiative extends far
beyond immediate ports of arrival
helping to lower Global food prices for
key food commodities around the world
the Secretary General has continued his
engagement with all parties in support
of the renewal and full implementation
of the initiative
he has also emphasized his commitment to
removing remaining obstacles to Russian
food and fertilizer exports
these products are not under
International sanctions but suffer
indirect impacts
it is important and critical to get them
back to World Markets the sooner the
better
Mr President the risk of nuclear
incident in the context of the open
hostilities in Ukraine remains an
unacceptable danger and I wish to S Echo
the serious concerns expressed by
numerous member states in this regard
the iaea director General has recently
briefed this Council on the
organization's latest efforts including
ongoing discussions regarding the zap
Parisian nuclear power plant as well as
assessments of activities and materials
at other sites in Ukraine
the iaea has reported that in the coming
weeks it will send nuclear Safety and
Security missions to three more
operating nuclear power plants as well
as to Chernobyl at the request of the
Ukrainian government
I reiterate the imperative to avoid any
military activity that could risk
compromising the Safety and Security of
any nuclear facility
Mr President since before the invasion
of 24 February the United Nations and
many others in the global Community
warned of the consequences of a wider
war in Ukraine for ukrainians first of
all but also for much of the world
these fears have amply worn out
one significant casualty of the war has
been the international collective
security system we have all pledged to
uphold
the damage to the structures built to
resolve or manage tensions and conflict
is significant
making it in turn even more difficult to
chart a path out of the hostilities in
Ukraine
there is only one way to stop the death
destruction and division the war must
end and it must end in line with
international law and the U.N Charter as
called for by the UN General Assembly
thank you Mr President
I thank Misty Carlo for her briefing
and I give the floor to those council
members who wish to make statements
I give the floor to the representative
of the United States
thank you Mr President
and thank you under Secretary General De
Carlo for your valuable briefing today
colleagues I want to start by noting the
tragic explosion that killed two people
in Poland near the Ukrainian border we
extend our deepest condolences to the
loved ones of those polish citizens who
were killed
as President Biden told president Duda
last night we stand with Poland in this
difficult moment and have offered our
full support for and assistance with
Poland's investigation to determine
exactly what happened
we have complete confidence in the
Polish government's investigation and
appreciate the calm careful and measured
response
while we still don't know all the facts
we do know one thing
this tragedy would never have happened
but for Russia's needless invasion of
Ukraine and its recent missile assaults
against Ukraine's civilian
infrastructure
the U.N Charter is clear
Ukraine has every right to defend itself
against this barrage
defend its sovereignty
defend this territorial integrity
the more than 90 missiles that rain down
on Kiev and other Targets in Ukraine
have devastated civilian infrastructure
in fact this may have been the widest
scale missile attack since the beginning
of the war
now millions of ukrainians are without
heat or electricity
we extend our solidarity to the
Ukrainian people for the Fallout of this
attack and our deepest condolences for
those lives lost
this is a deliberate tactic by Putin he
seems to have decided that if he can't
seize Ukraine by force he will try to
freeze the country into submission
it is hard to overstate how horrific
these attacks are
when I was in Ukraine last week I saw
firsthand the tremendous suffering these
kinds of attacks and this war has
wrought on the Ukrainian people and
Europe more broadly
I know we've all seen the photos of
cater cratered playgrounds bombed out
hospitals and destroyed homes across
Ukraine
but no photograph can capture the real
lives affected the real people suffering
the immense human toll of Russia's war
against the fellow U.N member state
I felt that toll when I spoke with the
mother and Kiev who had to hold her
daughter's lifeless body bloody hand
after a Russian attack on her apartment
building
her daughter and her mother's words just
wanted to go to school
I felt that toll when I met with a
humanitarian Aid worker who was detained
and tortured by Russian forces
she was so traumatized that she could
only share a portion of the horror as
she experienced unable to put the rest
into words
I felt that told when I met a 10 year
old named Molina
who lived in a facility where displaced
families were gathered to prepare for a
bitterly cold winter
a facility which itself had once been
hit and damaged by Russ Russian missiles
I was there to announce more than more
humanitarian funding from the United
States to provide supplies and support
while Russia prepared to weaponize the
winter
I made that announcement in the dark
during a blackout caused by Russian
attacks
afterwards I asked Molina what she would
do when the war was over
and I could tell that this was something
that she had given some thought to
she said simply she wanted to see her
best friend
who she had not seen since the start of
the war
and I have to say I wondered if she
would someday see her friend again
colleagues when I met with President
zielinski his message was simple
he seeks peace he told me he seeks a
just peace that is based on the U.N
Charter and its principles which is what
everyone in this council is here to
uphold and defend
we cannot say the same for Russia
as secretary blanken has told this
Council if Russia stops fighting this
war today the war ends if Ukraine stops
fighting Ukraine ends
it is Ukrainian civilians who are in
danger
it is Ukrainian civilians whose
electricity grids have been targeted who
aren't sure how they will keep warm
throughout the winter
it is Ukrainian civilians who are
suffering
there's one man sitting comfortably in
Moscow who can put a stop to this brutal
horrific War right now this second
but until he does we must address not
only the scale of the humanitarian and
human rights crisis unfolding in Ukraine
but also the continued spillover effects
of this needless War
just look at the outsized harm done by
Russia's exacerbation of the global food
security crisis
colleagues if you're looking for a
practical way to lower tensions and help
those in need it would be by supporting
and securing an extension of the Black
Sea grain initiative
according to the un's records nearly 500
ships carrying over 10 million metric
tons of grain and other food items have
departed under this initiative
that's enough to feed tens of millions
of people
the Black Sea grain initiative has
helped stabilize Food Markets with
reports that prices have fallen to
pre-war levels
two-thirds of the wheat exported under
the initiative has gone to the global
South
of the deadline for renewing the deal is
fast approaching
when I was in kieve I visited a granary
and heard that farmers need this deal to
be extended so they will have the
confidence to plant their wheat and
continue serving as a Bread Basket to
the developing world
I could hear the desperation in their
voices and I promised them that I would
take their message back to the security
Council
Russia must extend this essential
life-saving Arrangement Russia must
allow these ships to keep feeding the
world and I call on our fellow council
members to make the same calls with the
same urgency to keep the deal alive
in the long run the only way to ensure
Food Supplies are not impacted further
is for Russia to withdraw as troops stop
the atrocities and end the war
but in the meantime we're grateful for
the efforts of turkey and the U.N and
sustaining and expanding this
life-saving initiative and I hope
sincerely that we can continue to strive
with Ukraine in the driver's seat toward
a just and Lasting peace thank you Mr
President
I thank the representative of the United
States for the ass statement
I give the floor to the representative
of Albania
thank you Mr President and thank you
usgd caller for your comprehensive
update
here we are
with another meeting on Ukraine and yet
after nine months of brutal War we
continued to deplore loss of innocent
life countless unnecessary fatalities
widespread human misery massive
destruction food insecurity and a world
order shaken to its core
in a normal life nine months is the
period humans need to bring a baby to
life
Russia has used it to make a disaster of
terrible proportions including by making
normal life impossible to all including
to babies born in Ukraine since the 24th
of February for what reason for a dream
that has turned into a nightmare for a
miscalculation that has become an
obsession
Mr President
what some have feared and others had
anticipated happened yesterday
I miss I landed in a farm in Poland
killing two people it landed roughly at
the same time as a barrage of Russian
missiles attacked Western Ukraine
a full investigation is underway and we
look forward to his conclusions but this
does not change anything to the core
issue for as long as this war goes we
will run the risk of spillover by
accident or intention
this incident should be a stark reminder
that those who engage in the path of
unnecessary Reckless exhalation will
bear the consequences
we know and the world knows that
consequences of the war are not limited
to Ukraine only Moldova has already
complained about the effect of Russian
missiles fired close to its borders and
parts of its territory are experiencing
power outages as a result of Russian's
missiles hidden Ukrainian cities and
vital infrastructure
we present our condolences to the
families of the victims and to the
people of Poland and Ukraine we
reiterate our full and unwavering
solidarity with Poland just as with
other every other NATO member let's make
it clear this is not a war between
Russia and NATO nor is it between Russia
and the West it has never been despite
kremlin's propaganda to justify its
debacle
it is and remains a war of choice a pure
Act of unprovoked aggression
and an attempt to grab territory this
war must end not expand and Russia
started it Russia must put an end to it
and this is long time passed due
Mr President yesterday president
zielinski proposed a 10-point peace plan
at the G20 Summit in Indonesia
demonstrating leadership Again by making
clear he is prepared for diplomacy to
end the injust and unjustified War
the plan includes the past nuclear
safety food security a special Tribunal
for war crimes and a final peace treaty
with Russia
The Staggering response was a last but
not surprising another wave of missiles
its biggest in the month
targeting again residential areas and
power infrastructure in several regions
of the country with the aim to destroy
essential utilities such as electricity
water and gas infrastructure across
Ukraine
as the winter gets colder more than 7
million ukrainians are left without
power and the supply electricity in a
critical condition in this case there
was no error it looks like more terror
unable to Prevail on the ground Russia
has decided to weaponize everything
including weather now with the intention
to freeze an entire nation to submission
but it seems they fail to understand
that this fight in this fight Ukraine
has nothing more to lose the heroic
resistance of radio cranians has clearly
made it impossible for Russia to win and
a table to advance and incomprehensible
to acclaim
Mr President
Russia decided to withdraw its root for
Kirsten
it was not the first of such sudden
reversals they did so early this year
from the surroundings of kiv
no one including in Russia is buying any
more the camouflaged language the
so-called Special Operation cannot
conceal the Fiasco and the retreat
cannot hide the defeat only a few weeks
ago on 30 September Kremlin proclaimed
Carson to be Russian forever now a few
weeks later he just turned to what it
should be never
a wiser decision would be for Russia to
come to census seize all hostilities and
unconditionally withdraw all its forces
and military equipment from the entire
charity of Ukraine and let me reiterate
once more that any annexation of
territory by another state resulting
from the threat or use of force is a
violation of the principles of the
uncharter international law and will not
be accepted
Mr President the Russian Federation
continues to violate and blatantly lower
international law usgd Carlo mentioned
some key aspects of these violations the
use of missiles drones explosive weapons
in populative areas are prohibited by
international law including by binding
resolutions of this Council that Russia
has voted for
violations of human rights and
international law enforced disappearance
and arbitrary Detention of civilians
torture and ill treatment of both
civilians and prisoners cases of in
conflict-related sexual violence have
been widespread and now are well
documented these gross violations will
not go unpunished victims and their
family members seek Justice and
accountability
Russia may continue to block the council
but as we have seen repeatedly and
convincingly including last Monday they
will not manage to veto the decisions by
the by the unga and other initiatives to
seek and ensure reparations and
accountability
Mr President we reiterate our strong
support for the Black Sea Grand
initiative we retrate our call for its
extension Beyond 22nd November to keep
this vital food supply line open to the
rest of the world its impact is known
and felt worldwide and any decision any
other decision than extension would be a
cynical punishment of those in dire need
Mr President let me conclude by
reminding that the toll of the war is
already frightening
with every day going on the total will
be heavier for all for Ukraine first for
everybody including for Russia itself
in the course of the past nine months
nothing has gone according to plan in
Ukraine for the simple reason that the
Russian plan was wrong the intention
behind reprehensible and the reality has
proved disastrous it's time to change
course silence the guns pack and go home
talk piece not War I thank you
I thank the representative of Albania
for the ass statement I give the floor
to the representative of France
[Music]
Mr president
well the G20 leaders were meeting to
defend peace
Russia
once again demonstrated its
unscrupulousness by launching a new
campaign of strikes against Ukrainian
cities
it targeted civilian infrastructure in
so doing France condemns in the
strongest terms these strikes which
constitute flagrant violations of
international law we reaffirm our
support for Ukraine moreover I convey
Francis solidarity with Poland and our
condolences for the victims these were
conveyed Yesterday by President
McConnell yesterday evening to the
Polish prime minister Russia alone
shoulders the sole responsibility for
the this war
its mass strikes against Ukraine which
threaten International stability and
security and it is its strikes which may
lead to involuntary escalation Ukraine
is quite simply exercising its absolute
right to self-defense
with this aggression Russia is
deliberately violating the United
Nations Charter and namely the principle
of Ukraine's territorial Integrity since
the 16th of March the international
court of justice has called for the
suspension of Russia's military
operations soon nine months of War will
have elapsed and attacks against
civilians and civilian infrastructure
continue
Russia is now targeting power stations
and hydroelectric plants and heating
networks which are far behind the front
line with the apparent goal of breaking
the resistance of a people who is
fighting for its freedom
because it is losing ground Russia is
looking to plunge Ukraine into cold and
Into Darkness as winter draws near this
strategy is already a failure it is in
no way eroding the resistance of the
Ukrainian people on the contrary this
strategy is bolstering its determination
The Liberation of kerson is one more
illustration of that fact Mr President
more the more Russia digs its heels in
to make this world last the more it
worsens the energy food and economic
consequences of that war in recent weeks
in this very chamber we've heard Russia
increase its outrageous accusations
regarding the preparation of a dirty
bomb by Ukraine the inspections of the
international atomic energy agency which
were conducted in cave
zoftikodi and nipro at the request of
the Ukrainian authorities revealed no
Undeclared activity or material Ariel
now we have the confirmation that these
allegations were entirely unfounded
France hails the speed with which the
iaea
visited these sites in question and we
congratulate Ukraine for its
transparency Mr President Russia does
not hesitate to instrumentalize food
insecurity and malnutrition the fate of
millions of people depends upon the
extension of the Istanbul Accords after
having first of all suspended for
several days its participation in the
Black Sea grain initiative Russia is now
looking to
use its agreement to the renewal of
those Accords as a bargaining chip this
blackmail is unacceptable everything
must be done so that the exportations of
Ukrainian grain can continue without
obstruction we call upon Russia not to
hinder the renewal of the 22nd of July
Accords France will continue to support
the efforts of the Secretary General and
of turkey in this regard we will also
continue to Rally with our European
Partners as part of the solidarity Lanes
initiative these solidarity Lanes have
allowed the exportation Via waterways
and Overland of around 15 million tons
of grains and other food products I
recall that the European Union the
United States and the United Kingdom on
the 14th of November published
guidelines aiming to facilitate the
exportation of Russian fertilizers and
food products France announced a
contribution to the tune of 7.5 million
euros to facilitate the delivery by the
world food program of fertilizer to
Africa Mr President Russia will not be
able to evade its responsibility for
crimes committed in Ukraine I welcome
the adoption by the general assembly of
a resolution recommending the creation
of a register should document the damage
suffered by all Ukrainian victims France
Hales the courage and resistance of the
Ukrainian people we will continue to
stand by their side France will organize
jointly with Ukraine on the 13th of
December a conference to support Ukraine
this conference will aim to meet the
emergency needs
the Urgent needs on the ground and will
increase the supply of international Aid
whether we're talking here about
essential material or the Reconstruction
of critical infrastructure in particular
of energy infrastructure France
reiterates its unwavering support for
the sovereignty and territorial
Integrity of Ukraine in the face of
Russia's aggression we remain determined
to continue our support
for Ukraine's efforts to defend its
territory and will do so as long as is
necessary thank you
I thank the representative of France for
their statement I give the floor to the
representative of the United Kingdom
thank you president and thank you under
Secretary General De Carlo for your
briefing
I'd like to start by offering our
sympathies and condolences to the Polish
people
and to the families of those injured and
killed in yesterday's incident
while we await the outcome of the
investigation
we should be clear
that this is a tragedy that indisputably
stems from Russia's illegal and
unjustified invasion
and its inhumane assault on civilians
across Ukraine
yesterday
as president zielinski was setting out
to the G20 his 10-point plan for peace
in Ukraine
Ukrainian civilians were facing the
largest barrage of Russian missile and
drone strikes since the first week of
the war
we extend our condolences to the
Ukrainian people and the families of
those injured in these attacks
Russia's systematic attacks on Ukraine's
critical National infrastructure
have left Millions without electricity
heating water
medicine and food
as temperatures start to drop below zero
and more than that
today we've heard again from the UN
detailed reports of Civilian deaths
sexual violence
and forced deportation of children
Russia is knowingly trying to gain
military Advantage by creating
desperation
attacks of this kind May violate
International humanitarian law
aren't out and are in any event deeply
inhumane
president
on Monday the general assembly adopted a
resolution on an international mechanism
for reparations for damage loss and
injury
arising from Russia's internationally
wrongful acts against Ukraine
this was an important first step towards
Justice for Ukraine
president
we are in no doubt that Ukraine will
prevail in the face of Russia's
aggression
The Liberation of her son
shows the strength courage and
determination of the Ukrainian people
to defend their right to Sovereign
equality and territorial Integrity
guaranteed under the UN Charter and the
UK will continue to stand by the
Ukrainian people
but while the war is ongoing
we must continue also to manage its
wider effects as best we can
that is why we strongly support the
Black Sea grain initiative
it has been vital in helping alleviate
the serious risks of food insecurity in
the world
and we strongly support the UN in the
efforts to renew it
president fundamentally
this war is the result of unilateral
action on the part of the Russian
Federation
the path forward is therefore simple
Russia needs to cease hostilities
withdraw from within Ukraine's
internationally recognized borders
and commit to a path of dialogue
thank you
I thank the representative of the United
Kingdom for the ass statement
I give the floor to the representative
of the United Arab Emirates
thank you Mr President first the United
Arab Emirates extends its heartfelt
condolences to Poland for the two
civilians killed in yesterday's incident
the news of missiles hitting polish
territory and the increases in strikes
across Ukraine seemed to Signal the
frightening escalation many of us have
talked about In This Very Room it
perfectly demonstrated the fact that as
the fighting continues each day becomes
a gamble in which there cannot be any
winners
Mr President the humanitarian situation
in Ukraine is a source of profound
concern with Winter's onset 40 percent
of the country's power system is
reportedly damaged and 30 percent of its
power stations are destroyed potentially
compounding the humanitarian crisis with
a lack of heating
around the world governments continue to
warn of the war's consequences on the
global food supply most recently at the
G20 Summit in Indonesia in addition to
the export of grains the supply of
ammonia and fertilizers which are
crucial to ensure adequate crop yields
for next year's Harvest are also a
priority as the Secretary General has
said we cannot let this year's crisis of
affordability become next year's crisis
of availability
we joined the call to renew the black
seed grain initiative and we urge the
stakeholders to reach a solution that
ensures the extension of these
agreements a critical breakthrough for
which we are grateful to the UN and
turkey
similarly we commend Ocha and the other
humanitarian actors for their tireless
efforts to provide Ukrainian civilians
with essential supplies including the
recent convoys to Southern Ukraine
as humanitarian assistance and efforts
to renew the grain initiative continue
we must acknowledge that this is not
enough only a sustainable and peaceful
resolution of the war will put an end to
the suffering it has caused we are
encouraged by the recent public
statements discussing the Contours of a
possible peace agreement this Council
must play its part to support any
efforts at talks and we must focus on
measures that can bring the sides
together rather than further apart
Mr President
last month marked the 60th anniversary
of the Cuban Missile Crisis
back then pragmatic and inventive
diplomacy brought the world back from
the brink public statements which
counseled calm and restraint in response
to the news from Poland and which to
emphasized the need to establish facts
on the ground helped avoid further
escalation within the last 24 hours
but the overall episode was an unnerving
warning of the risks inherent in the
continuation of the war this cannot be
the new normal too much is at stake not
least of which for Ukraine
we recall here the statement that came
out of the G20 we must uphold
international law and the multilateral
system defend the U.N Charter and adhere
to International humanitarian law
beginning with
urgently needed de-escalation we must
encourage confidence building measures
and open channels of communication to
end this conflict and to ensure that
today's era is not an era of War thank
you
I thank the representative of the United
Arab Emirates for the ass statement I
give the floor to the representative of
Mexico
thank you president
we're grateful to under Secretary
General Rosemarie De Carlo for her
briefing
the missiles that fell yesterday in
Poland
in independently of their origin or or
um whether it was intentional or not or
a source of great concern and we'd like
to express our condolences to the
families of the victims who died as a
result of these Unfortunate Events this
incident
reminds us that the risks of an
expansion of this conflict are real and
they
Force us to increase our efforts to find
a diplomatic solution quickly to put an
end to the suffering of the civilian
population in the entire region I would
like to refer to Four Points first of
all
I'd like to mention the humanitarian
situation
in addition to the damage accumulated
during the nine months of the conflict
now
we have the destruction of the electric
infrastructure just as uh and the
beginning of winter
the lack of electricity compromises many
other basic Services just I'll give an
example the supply of water
and all this of course
puts at even greater risk the life and
health of millions of civilians
if the deterioration of living
conditions will continue there will be a
new wave of displacements at a time when
host communities are already at the
limit of their capacities
the figures are quite eloquent
7.8 million ukrainians have had to
abandon their country while another 6
million
have become internally displaced
in this context humanitarian assistance
has become essential for the survival of
especially the most vulnerable
population we'd like to reiterate our
appeal to allow unrestricted access to
all civilian population including
the areas the occupied areas the oblasts
that are occupied where martial law has
been decreed
now although it's perhaps less obvious
the conflict has also had very severe
consequences on the mental health of the
population
the more than 400 uh
children killed and some
270 disappeared are a very tragic
demonstration of the pain that this war
is causing
Mexico would like to reiterate how
important it is to include the Psycho
Social uh Support Services in the
humanitarian response strategy the
consequences uh on mental health will
not end when the conflict finishes which
is why it will be essential to develop a
long-term strategy to deal with this
dimension of the conflict
a dimension that is both silent and
painful secondly I'd like to mention the
issue of nuclear Safety and Security the
situation around the zapparesia nuclear
power plant continues to be a source of
great alarm we'd like to reiterate the
appeal to establish a protection and
security Zone around the plant as
has been proposed by the international
atomic energy agency Mexico acknowledges
the work of the iaea in particular for
the verification of the three sites
on which one of the parties had some
doubts regarding the activities that
were taking place there
we'd like to take note of the fact that
the agency concluded that there is no
evidence of any nuclear activity or
non-declared materials we will continue
to follow very tentatively the results
of visits to other to the other three
nuclear power plants including Chernobyl
in the next few weeks
while there's no doubt that the
situation in the zeparesia power plant
is critical it's also important to
underscore that during a conflict such
as this one all nuclear facilities could
become a disaster for the population and
for the environment
thirdly I'd like to refer to the Black
Sea grain initiative
this s has been stated here has been
essential to help mitigating food
insecurity that mainly affects
developing countries
this is why it is essential that this
initiative to continue and that the
agreements signed to facilitate access
to global markets of food products and
fertilizers from Russia is fully
implemented including ammonium
we would like to recognize that the
efforts of the Secretary General to
eliminate the huge
amount of obstacles that the exports of
these products have encountered
these agreements have been a sign of
Hope for those who believe in dialogue
and in diplomacy as ways of reaching a
solution of the conflict in spite of the
multiple disagreements
that often appear to be almost
insurmountable lastly Mr President I
would like to mention that is extremely
important to make progress in
international investigations to ensure
accountability
those that have committed crimes in this
conflict
must
uh resp must be brought to Justice the
International Community owes this at
least this to the victims and to their
families
this is why we will continue to follow
very attentively the work that the
international criminal court is
conducting on this point in conclusion
I'd like to reiterate that Mexico and
would like to insist on the need to
explore new formulas that would promote
mediation and dialogue to put an end to
this war Mr President
Mexico would like to reiterate its
support to this sovereignty Independence
and territorial Integrity of Ukraine
thank you
I thank the representative of Mexico for
their statement I give the floor to the
representative of Kenya
thank you Mr President
I thank and Secretary General Rosemary
decala for her briefing
and the briefing we have had today
makes it clear that the war in Ukraine
continues to cause extreme suffering to
civilians far beyond what is acceptable
under international law and
international humanitarian law
we offer our condolences to all the
families and communities that have lost
loved ones to this world including
in the incident that happened yesterday
in Poland
we pray for the spirit recovery of those
injured and traumatized
we are gravely concerned by the
persistent targeting of civilians and
objects indispensable to their survival
including residential homes
Health Facilities
shelters as well as energy and water
infrastructure
this war
that follows on a long-term political
conflict is a violation of Ukraine's
territorial integrity
and constitutes a bridge of the
fundamental principles of the U.N
Charter
the military alliances
forming on either side are giving the
war a regional and Global footprint
the risk of its escalation to the use of
weapons of mass destruction
suggests
the ultimate inability over clear
military victory at a cost that is
acceptable to humanity
there is no long-term military solution
all that a continuation of the world
will do is delay negotiations while even
greater damage is happening
Kenya therefore once again calls for an
immediate cessation of hostilities
negotiations will not be easy
especially
if they are to be fully in line with the
U.N Charter
in protecting the sovereignty and
territorial Integrity of Ukraine
but they can succeed as others have in
New in Europe's volatile history
it will also be critical that they be
accompanied or followed by a broader
settlement that stabilizes what is now a
profoundly compromised European security
order
Mr President
the world needs peace in Ukraine and in
Europe
the humanitarian cost to the people of
Ukraine are joined by those of millions
around the world
we continue to applaud the humanitarian
inspired a new and facilitated Black Sea
grain initiative
we strongly urge for its renewal on
permanent towns
the flow of grains and fertilizers from
Ukraine
over the Black Sea and also from the
Russian Federation over the land
corridors must be assured
unfortunately
they are still unilateral blockages of
food and fertilizer products despite the
frequent assurances
to the contrary
we therefore are the Secretary General
to urgently undertake an assessment
of official and unofficial blockages and
to make that report available to the
security Council
the same should be done by humanitarian
organizations such as the world world
food program
we also encourage Regional organizations
such as the European Union and Afric and
the African Union to reveal and report
on the experiences of their member
states in ensuring an impeded exports of
Ukrainian and Russian food and
fertilizer to World Markets
our region the Horn of Africa is
experiencing the worst drought in
decades
we cannot afford to pay for exceedingly
expensive fertilizer if we are to avoid
a worse food insecurity situation in the
coming year
we must move from political assurances
of the open floor of these vital Goods
and transparently and vigorously
assessed and Report the facts on the
ground
millions of lives depend on this orgas
house going Beyond rhetoric and
guaranteeing practical effects
Mr President
the crisis presents an opportunity
Africa is the most food insecure region
in the world
yet it has the largest amount of
underused arable land with a population
that is still mostly rural best
Too Many African families use a
disproportionate part of their incomes
on purchasing food
is a major component of the political
instability that sadly leads to the
continent having the most conflict
situations being handled by the security
Council
we now have a historic opportunity to
put in place Financial Risk mitigation
technology transfers and Investments to
transform agricultural productivity on
the continent
while we commend the humanitarian
efforts being made to offer relief our
Target must be sufficient production
the efficacy of the continent's
cooperation agreements with other
regions and major Powers should be
judged by the extent to which they lead
to a surge in Africa's production of
food and fertilizer so that is never
again as vulnerable as it is today
Mr President
the more product protracted this war is
the more it's maligned effects will
spread
and small citizens suffer
in more countries
there are political demands may lead to
less worldwide solidarity with the
suffering people of Ukraine
every country calling for this
solidarity must look into its conduct
when it comes to enabling the free flow
of food and fertilizer products and act
with compassion and empathy for those
who need them around the world in
closing Kenya once again reiterates its
respect for the sovereignty territorial
integrity and political independence of
Ukraine I thank you
I thank the representative of Kenya for
their statement
I give the floor to the representative
of India
Mr President let me Begin by thanking
under Secretary General Rosemary di
Carlo for her briefing and update of the
situation in Ukraine
India continues to remain concerned
about the situation in Ukraine including
the targeting of Civilian infrastructure
and the death of civilians
since the beginning of the conflict
India has consistently called for an
immediate cessation of hostilities and
for an end to the violence we have
called upon both sides to return to the
path of diplomacy and dialogue and have
also expressed our support for all
diplomatic efforts to end the conflict
we thus stand ready to support all
efforts aimed at de-escalation India's
prime minister has said unequivocally
that this cannot be an era of War we
hope that the International Community
will continue to respond positively to
the call for humanitarian assistance
India has so far dispatched 12
Consignments of humanitarian Aid to
Ukraine and stands ready to do more
Mr President I will also state that the
impact of the Ukraine conflict has not
just been limited to Europe the global
South is specially facing serious
Economic Consequences we are also seeing
growing concerns on energy and food
security from the conflict that follow
the severe stress created by two years
of the covet pandemic
insofar as specific initiatives
pertaining to issues like food grains
and fertilizer shipments are concerned
we very much hope that the UN
facilitated Black Sea grain and
fertilizer package deal will be renewed
in coming days and that this will be
implemented by all parties earnestly in
all its aspects
I wish to assure this Council Mr
President that India's approach to the
Ukraine conflict will continue to be
people-centric we are providing both
humanitarian assistance to Ukraine and
economic support to some of our
neighbors in the global South under
economic distress in closing may I
reiterate that the global order is
anchored on the principles of the U.N
Charter international law and respect
for the sovereignty and territorial
Integrity of all states thank you Mr
President
I thank the representative of India for
their statement
I give the floor to the representative
of Gabon
thank you Mr President
I thank Ms Rosemary DeCarlo for her
enlightening briefing
Mr President the war in Ukraine will
soon enter its ninth month and it seems
that there are no signs of
a de-escalation or of a cessation of
hostilities on the horizon we hail the
resumption of export exports as part of
the grain initiative following a brief
suspension the implementation of the
agreement must be grounded in the firm
and good faith commitment of all parties
here I wish to Echo the appeal issued by
the Secretary General for the renewal of
this important agreement and for its
full and balanced implementation the
resumption of the grain initiative is a
sign that even in times of war the
channels of dialogue and diplomacy
remain open Mr President the war in
Ukraine continues to have many
humanitarian consequences
these have prompted the mass
disclosement of people fleeing these
sites of the fighting these humanitarian
consequences have also produced many
civilian victims and much material many
material losses the cost of which are
incalculable ongoing insecurity and the
disruption of Supply chains have plunged
many people into hunger and distress the
primary victims of vulnerable persons
namely women and children these people
are often the victims of sexual violence
of trafficking in persons and of
manifold violations of their fundamental
human rights once again we call upon the
warring parties to uphold International
humanitarian law and to refrain from
inflicting suffering on civilians
civilian infrastructure including
civilian nuclear sites must not be the
target of attacks and humanitarian Aid
must be delivered without impediment my
country reiterates that it opposes the
use of any weapon of mass destruction we
call for dialogue dialogue and for
negotiations in good faith in order to
achieve a ceasefire Gabon supports and
will continue to support all efforts
aiming to find a diplomatic solution
able to guarantee the peaceful
coexistence of all parties I thank you
Mr President
I thank the representative of Gabon for
their statement I give the floor to the
representative of Ireland
thank you president and thank you USG
DeCarlo for your briefing I also want to
open by expressing our condolences to
the Polish people following the
explosion in a small Border Town of
Birchwood of yesterday which killed two
people we extend our deepest sympathies
to the families of those killed and
injured
we also fully support Poland
investigation of the incident and we
stand in full solidarity with Poland
president Russia has launched hundreds
of drone and missile strikes in recent
weeks in Ukraine with the apparent aim
of terrorizing and demoralizing the
civilian population
yesterday Russia scaled up with strikes
with further attacks in Kiev and across
Ukraine
while Russia seeks to escalate the war
millions of people across Ukraine Are
Tonight grappling with the prospect of a
dark and freezing winter without
reliable access to water heat
electricity and other basic services
the most vulnerable in Ukrainian Society
the internally displaced children and
the elderly face a particularly
precarious future
women already disproportionately
impacted by the war are once again put
an unsafe and precarious situations
that this may be the intended result of
recent Russian attacks on Ukraine cities
and infrastructure is simply
unconscionable
this includes efforts to remove zapure
from the Ukrainian grid and attacks in
other Ukrainian nuclear facilities
this Auto disregard for nuclear safety
carries the strong risk of a nuclear
incident with terrible consequences for
Ukraine Russia and the wider region
we stress the importance of the Seven
Pillars of nuclear Safety and Security
and their applicability in armed
conflict as set out by the iaea director
General
we condemn these heinous attacks in the
strongest possible terms
attacks intentionally directed against
civilians and civilian objects are war
crimes and those responsible for such
attacks must be held to account
Mr President the people of Ukraine have
shown remarkable resolve and
determination in the face of brutal
adversity
Ireland stands with them today as always
we are very concerned by reports of
heavy fighting in the East where living
conditions for the civilian population
are increasingly dire and where Russian
forces continue to attack particularly
around the city of bakmud and other
towns in the region
the South we cautiously welcome The
Liberation of the city of herzan and
note the decision of the Russian
leadership to withdraw to the Eastern
Bank of the nepro river
we are called a party to the conflict
most comply with International and
humanitarian law
this includes the prohibitions against
indiscriminate and disproportionate
attacks and the obligation to take all
feasible precautions in attack
there must also be full safe and
unhindered humanitarian access to
civilians in need including those who
choose to remain or who are unable to
leave
those who seek to leave and those who
are forced to leave must be allowed to
do so safely and be allowed to leave for
destinations of their own choosing
we note that thousands of civilians were
reportedly evacuated by the Russian army
before its withdrawal from her son
hundreds of thousands of ukrainians have
been moved from russian-occupied
territories
we recall that the transfer or
deportation of civilians by an occupying
power from occupied territory can
constitute a war crime
refugees internally displaced and Status
persons are particularly at risk of
exploitation with attacks and abductions
that lead to trafficking
women and children face particular
danger in disregard and must be
protected from harm
conflict-related sexual violence is
never acceptable and again May amount to
war crimes
Mr President duty reverberations of this
war continue to be felt far beyond
Ukraine's borders with unequal and
disproportionate impacts on developing
countries
the Black Sea Grand initiative plays an
important role in alleviating Global
Food Security in security and I should
continue to do so in the months ahead
we are grateful for the efforts of the
UN and turkey a to facilitate Russia's
resume participation in the agreement
we urge all sides to maintain engagement
and good faith and continue this
important initiative
Mr President we have set out many of
these concerns on many previous
occasions at this table and I fear we
will do so again
but as my Minister for foreign affairs
said earlier today Ireland will make no
apology for being on the side of
international law the U.N Charter and on
the side of Ukraine and its people
Russia should end its illegal war of
aggression stop killing innocent
civilians and shelling of infrastructure
with immediate effect
it is never too late for dialogue and
diplomacy we therefore renew our call on
Russia to immediately seek hostilities
withdraw its forces and commit to
resolving all outstanding issues
peacefully underlined with the UN
Charter thank you
I thank the representative of Ireland
for the ass statement
I give the floor to the representative
of Brazil
thank you Mr President
Mr President
I thank USG decalo for her briefing
Brazil shares the concerns regarding the
worsening humanitarian situation in
Ukraine and the impact of the conflict
on food Security in other regions
since the start of hostilities we have
advocated for the parties to engage in
negotiations for a ceasefire and a
peaceful solution to their differences
the Black Sea initiative which has
already enabled exports of more than 10
million metric tons of grain has been an
important step
Brazil welcomes the decision of the
Russian Federation to reconsider the
suspension of its participation
following the incidence of 29 October
while the conflict in Ukraine is not the
only cause of the food insecurity we now
face
the continuation of grain and fertilizer
exports
through Black Sea ports helps stabilize
prices and prevent shortages
fragilities in global food supply
however stem from systemic actions over
past decades that have hindered the
development of the Agricultural sector
throughout the developing World in
particular in Africa
among these we must recognize the
deleterious impact of massive
agricultural subsidies and distorting
tariff and non-tariff barriers that hold
back agricultural production in
developing countries
we renew our support for the mediation
efforts of the Secretary General and the
Republic of Turkey
we encourage the parties to engage in
the immediate extension of the green
initiative which we see as a necessary
decision and an important confidence
building measure
Mr President
the approach of winter of winter finds
Ukrainian cities in an alarming
situation
the destruction of civil infrastructure
particularly in the energy sector
exposes millions of families to
life-threatening conditions
Brazil strongly condemns the attacks
against residential areas and civilian
facilities for which there is no
justification
we urge all parties to uphold their
obligations under International
humanitarian law and to adopt practical
measures to minimize civilian injuries
and damages on the ground
at this challenging time the
International Community needs to stand
together in humanitarian assistance to
Ukraine
since March contributions of food and
medical supplies have been shipped from
our country to Ukraine
in the coming weeks Brazil sent 24
additional tons of rice donated by the
private sector
the Brazilian government has also
simplified entry requirements in order
to facilitate the reception of refugees
it is encouraging to see that this wave
of solidarity is observed in dozens of
countries we urge governments and the
private sector to engage in similar
initiatives which have never been more
urgent since the beginning of the
conflict
Mr President finally we renew the call
for the parties to return to the
negotiating table without delay
we encourage other members to explore
ways to foster dialogue there is no more
urgent task facing the United Nations
than the search for an immediate
ceasefire without preconditions I thank
you Mr President
I thank the representative of Brazil for
their statement
I give the floor to the representative
of China
thank you Mr President
Mr President
the Ukraine crisis is getting
increasingly protected expanded and
complex
putting further stress on the current
tense International situation
and bringing greater uncertainty to the
world
which is not in interest of any party
no matter how many difficulties and
challenges there are the international
communities would strive to seek
consensus find room for cooperation
and the player constructive and
responsible role in promoting the
de-escalation of the situation
restarting diplomatic negotiations as
soon as possible and mitigating the
spill over effects of the crisis in the
current context China believes that the
International Community should continue
to make efforts along the following
directions
first we should work jointly to support
the peaceful resolution of the crisis a
conflict or War has no winners dialogue
and negotiations are the only viable way
out of the Ukraine crisis as long as
negotiation starts there is hope for
peace
China knows that Russia has expressed
its willingness to engage in Dialogue on
many occasions in recent days in hopes
that the party's concerned will move in
the same direction respond positively
and start direct engagement as soon as
possible to create conditions for
restarting negotiations
there are no Simple Solutions to complex
issues
on the basis of accommodating each
other's legitimate security concerns
parties should explore the construction
of a balanced effective and sustainable
European security architecture
so as to fundamentally address the
security deficit behind the crisis
and Achieve peace and stability on the
European continent it is our hope that
the United States NATO and Russia will
conduct a comprehensive dialogues on
this matter China will continue to play
a constructive role in its own way
about the meteor report
the landing of a missile in the Eastern
Village of Poland and resulting in
casualties
China calls on all relevant parties to
keep calm and exercise restraint to
avoid misunderstanding and risk
calculation to avoid the further
escalation of the situation
second
we should work jointly to prevent
nuclear risks nuclear safety security
and the safeguards
pair on
public health and environmental safety
in Ukraine and neighboring regions there
is no room for trial and error in this
regard all parties concerned should
exercise restraints act prudently
strictly abide by the convention on
nuclear safety and other international
law ensure the safety of nuclear
facilities and material in Ukraine and
do their utmost to avoid any possible
nuclear risks
China supports the iaea in fulfilling
its functions in accordance with this
mandate and playing active role with
regard to nuclear safety
China has always maintained that a
nuclear war cannot be won and must never
be false
we have noted the recent statement
issued by Russia reaffirming the
relevant elements of the January joint
statement of the leaders of the five
nuclear weapon States on preventing
nuclear war and avoiding arms races the
International Community should work
together to maintain Global strategic
stability make every effort to avoid
confrontation between major Powers
Advocate that nuclear weapons must never
be used and the nuclear war must never
be fought and prevent a nuclear crisis
in Asia and Europe
third we should work together to improve
the humanitarian situation
China is deeply concerned about the
continued deterioration of humanitarian
situation in Ukraine and relates deeply
to the difficulties experienced by the
people of Ukraine and the neighboring
regions we call our parties concerned to
earnestly abide by International
humanitarian law make every effort to
avoid attacks targeting civilians in the
civilian facilities minimize civilian
casualties in the impact on people's
basic livelihoods and prevent to the
maximum possible
larger-scale humanitarian crisis
this winter will be very hard for the
affected population in the countries
concerned and the neighboring regions
the International Community and the
humanitarian agencies should continue to
scale up relief efforts to help
alleviate humanitarian pressure and
improve humanitarian situation in
Ukraine and neighboring regions
and ensure that all refugees displace
the persons and other people in need can
be properly resettled and safely survive
the winter
Force we should work together to
mitigate the spill over effects of the
crisis the Black Sea Green initiative
has made a positive contribution to
alleviating the global food crisis China
welcomes the efforts by all parties to
adhere to the humanitarian principles
and focus on the overall situation by
resuming the implementation of the
initiative and costs on all parties to
maintain Corporation dialogue in order
to reach a proper Solution on the
extension of the initiative China
supports the U.S Secretary General and
his team in continuing to play a
coordinating role in resolving the
difficulties in Russian food and
fertilizer exports
we call on the relevant parties to take
robust measures to eliminate the
negative impact of sanctions managing
properly the huge impact of the Ukraine
crisis on global energy food finance and
other fields is a pressing task for the
International Community
sleeping and indiscriminate sanctions
disrupt the global industrial and Supply
chains undermine the momentum of the
global economic recovery and damage the
economic and financial stability of
developing countries
immediate actions must be taken to
rectify this approach
Mr President
the world is undergoing momentous
changes I see in the century the Ukraine
crisis and its spillover effects as an
epitome of the changes highlight the
major challenges facing human
development
what is wrong with the world and what
should we do about it this is the
question of our times to all countries
I just concluded G20 Summit
president Xi Jinping with deep Insight
on the future of humanity and from a
historical and Global Perspective put
forward a series of initiatives and
propositions
which are of great significance for
guiding the efforts to address the
current Global challenges
China calls on all countries to embrace
the vision of a community with a shared
future for mankind and Advocate the
peace development and women cooperation
all countries should replace division
with unity confrontation with
cooperation
and Extrusion with inclusiveness
all countries should join hands together
to tide over difficulties and create a
better future
China firmly opposes drawing ideological
lines
Cold War mentality
group politics and block confrontation
China rejects bigger Thy Neighbor
practices and practices of building a
small yard with high fences or creating
closed and exclusive clubs China also
opposes the attempt to politicize
economic and livelihood issues or use
them as tools and weapons China stands
ready to work with the rest of the world
and continue to make Relentless efforts
to address Global challenges and build a
community with a shared future for
mankind thank you Mr President
I thank the representative of China for
their statement I give the floor to the
representative of Norway
thank you president
USD di kolu thank you for your very
useful briefing
yesterday the Russian army inflicted
massive waves of missile strikes on
Ukraine with civilians being killed
and in Poland we saw an explosion
resulting in the tragic loss of Polish
lives
we are in close contact with our allies
and partners and support the ongoing
investigation
what we do now however is that this
would not have happened had it not been
for Russia's illegal war on Ukraine
one only needs to look at kerson to see
further evidence of their brutal
campaign against civilians
we see in the wake of Russia's first
retreat
atrocities and destruction
they did what they could to make the
situation as difficult as possible for
the civilian population
destroying water heat and electricity
supplies and they continue these tactics
across the country
with winter approaching the number of
casualties and displaced persons could
accelerate children the elderly and
other people in highly vulnerable
situations are particularly at risk
we call for safe rapid and unimpeded
access for humanitarian organizations to
all people in need including access to
prisoners of War
we commend the UN International
Committee of the Red Cross and other
humanitarian Organization for staying
and delivering a principled humanitarian
response under very challenging
circumstances and also their courageous
and committed Ukrainian responders
with Richard also our demand that all
civilians must be protected
in National humanitarian law an
international human rights law must be
fully respected and implemented
international law applies to all nations
it is not optional
president the suffering and the atrocity
committed by Russian armed forces have
shocked the whole world
the consequences are felt globally
Russia's war of aggression is causing a
refugee tragedy with a regional impact
and is destabilizing financial markets
Supply chains and disrupting Global
energy security
the world most vulnerable people and
countries depend on us that the supply
of food from Ukraine and Russia to
Global markets it is essential to keep a
transportation Line open for the exports
of grain related food stuff and
fertilizers like this including ammonia
considering the dire Global consequences
with trust the parties will stay
committed to the Black Sea grain deal
and that these life-saving shipments
will continue
president Russia's war of aggression
demonstrates that disregard for the core
principles of our organization and the
suffering of millions of people in the
wake of this war
as members of the security Council it is
our duty to set a different cause as the
Secretary General has emphasized we have
the values and principles necessary to
chart this course
they are already enshrined in the
shutter of the United Nations
when the time comes we will stand firmly
with the Secretary General in efforts to
build and sustain peace in Ukraine
we will work actively to ensure that
this Council remains Vigilant of the
situation in Ukraine unable to address
the host of other conflict on its agenda
let me end by repeating something we
have said numerous times before and yet
it cannot be said often enough
through its aggression and actions the
Russian Federation is acting with
blatant disregard to international law
Russia must immediately heed the ruling
of the icj and the cause of these United
Nations to suspend its military
operation within Ukraine's
internationally recognized border and
stop the senseless Bloodshed and Global
suffering thank you
I thank the representative of Norway for
their statement I now give the flaw to
the representative of the Russian
Federation
Mr President
we're very grateful to our Albanian and
American colleagues for the initiative
of conducting today's meeting
it's true that they requested it last
week without even stating the topic of
the meeting and in that as we now see
they demonstrated remarkable
farsightedness
if this meeting had not been scheduled
we would have had to convene it to
discuss the attempts by Ukraine and
Poland to provoke a direct clash between
Russia and NATO
now the uh completely responsible
statements made by the leaders of this
of these two countries cannot be
interpreted any other way for example
statement by Mr zielinski and I quote
we must put the terrorist in his place
the more Russia feels its impunity the
greater the threat for anyone who is
within the range of Russian missiles
a missile strike on the territory of
NATO is a Russian missile strike against
collective security this is a very
serious escalation we must act and end
of quote
then on he expressed condolences to
Poland in connection with the people
killed as a result of the Russian
missile attack while stating and I'm
quoting Russia kills anywhere where it
can reach end of quote
I would like to draw the attention of
colleagues these are statements made by
a man who cannot fail to have access to
information that it was Ukrainian
missiles across into polish territory
launched by Ukrainian air defense
systems that means that it's this is not
just an intentional attempt to
disinformation but a conscious attempt
to involve NATO which is conducting a
proxy war with Russia in Ukraine to
involve it into a direct conflict with
our country
now the russophobic authorities of
Poland weren't very far off from the
very beginning they unequivocally stated
that they were the target of Russian
attack the foreign Ministry of this
country summoned the Russian Ambassador
in the middle of the night to register
their Resolute protest and this in spite
of the fact that uh photos published in
the social media in the wake of the
event leave no doubt that it was
Ukrainian air defense missiles that
cross into Poland
and now this has been confirmed even by
now by NATO and overall in the West
if not for that uh for for that all
these uh facts would be concealed from
the public uh in order to promote the
version of Russian guilt however it's
very difficult to deny the obvious just
as in the history of the uh
missile strike by the Ukrainian Armed
Forces against kramatosk on the 8th of
April which Ukraine tried to pass off as
a Russian crime however photos of
witnesses who happened to be there
derail this intentional and brutal
provocation
our former Western pardon is now don't
like to remember that
and the Kiev regime has since then
introduced punishment against all those
who published on social media materials
that show consequences of any military
strikes this way because the Ukrainian
citizens could involuntarily thwart the
provocation of their authorities
now returning to this tragic incident I
cannot fail to mention that Ukrainian
air defense systems have long had a bad
reputation
at least since the moment when in
October of 2001 over the Black Sea
during military exercises a Russian
civilian airliner was shot down flying
from Tel Aviv to Nova sabirsk 78 people
died on board many recalled also the
tragedy of of that tragedy in 2014 when
over the donbassad the Malaysian Boeing
was shot down the so-called
International investigators which who
included Ukraine didn't even consider as
a matter of principle the possibility of
Ukraine's responsibility for that
disaster and over the past few months we
regularly see footage about the
consequence of Ukrainian air defense
missiles falling on residential homes
which were used to conceal these systems
there are clumsy attempts to pass off
these incidents as consequences of
Russian strikes carried out with high
Precision weapons against the military
targets and critical infrastructure
while keeping silent that in case of a
direct hit by such high Precision
weapons there will be nothing left of
these homes
distinguished colleagues we have long
ago stopped being surprised by your
attempts in any circumstances in spite
of facts or common sense to blame Russia
for everything and so today in spite of
clear evidence of the Ukrainian polish
provocation many representatives of
Western countries have stated to the
effect that even if the missiles were
launched by Ukraine it's still Russia
who's to blame for uh destroying
critical infrastructure
the lameness of this logic manifests
itself in all its Glory as it applies to
the irresponsible shelling of zepharosa
power plant you as everyone knows
Ukraine is behind that shelling
some of you have repeated your favorite
cunning mantra
if not if it if it weren't for Russia we
would not find ourselves in this
situation well I want to for the
umpteenth time remind you we would not
find ourselves in this situation if not
for the fact that in 2014 in Kiev with
the direct participation of a number of
Western States a bloody
anti-constitutional coup had not taken
place and the leaders of that coup chose
from the very first day the path of
distorting history and driving out the
use of the Russian language and thus
provoked an acute internal civilian
conflict and we would not be discussing
today what we're discussing if you
didn't abet the key of regime and its
unwillingness to uh
to fulfill the Minsk agreements and
didn't provide cover for its
eight-year-long war against the
inhabitants of the donbas and that case
we would not have had to begin the
special military operation to protect
the population of the donbass and if you
had not interfered it did not supply
Ukraine with weapons and ammunitions if
you encourage the Ukrainian leadership
to strive for peace on realistic terms
rather than fuel its feverish fantasies
about the possibility of victory over
Russia for the sake of which the
zelinski regime's essentially
senselessly throwing tens of thousands
of its soldiers into the meat grinder
if you reacted to the terrorist actions
of the Ukrainian Special Forces against
Russia we would not be forced to conduct
Precision strikes on infrastructure
but since you're acting as you're acting
and while the Kiev regime is taking
credit for non-existent military prowess
we are forced to achieve the goals set
for the special military operation by
weakening the military potential of
Ukraine which was created first and
foremost
due to the uh
due to the unlimited supplies of Western
weaponry
now we are used to the fact that
Ukraine cannot be criticized
any Crimes by the by the key of regime
are a priori ignored or the blame is
shifted to Russia
we are used to the the the disgusting
fake material against Russia and its
Armed Forces I just want to ask you a
rhetorical question
has any one of you for once commented on
the repression and brutality that the
representatives on the Kiev regime have
conducted on territory under its control
against peaceful inhabitants uh the the
kind of words they used to describe them
and and the kind of atrocities they they
uh con they subject to now it's taking
place in Harrison in Kirsten earlier it
took place in other cities all this is
available in the public domain I will
answer for you no all this is is
outside your scope of vision outside of
your Horizon and not within your
selective conscience
so when you criticize someone look at
yourselves in the mirror and while
you're at it don't forget how you to
remember how you arrogantly rejected the
proposed discussion of issues of
European security
clinging to the sacred Rite of NATO to
expand without heeding the concerns of
other countries
Mr President well
since we are have gathered here I want
to recall the involvement of NATO
countries in the Ukrainian conflict they
continue flooding Ukraine with weapons
and sending
teams of instructors and foreign
mercenaries to work with that with his
weapons
at the same time the U.S military has
actively become involved in planning and
de facto control over the conduct of
military activities which was recently
officially recognized by the Pentagon we
have no doubt how Western military
technology is used for targeted strikes
against civilian facilities just over
the past week frequent artillery
barrages have been fired including using
highmar's multiple rocket launchers
against the Central and residential
parts of Donetsk yesi novate
and other cities and even the cities
that Belgrade or Obelisk of Russia
and Strikes continue to be conducted
against the kahovska hydroelectric plant
which could lead to a major humanitarian
disaster we have no Illusions why this
is necessary for the West for the West
Ukraine is interiorly a testing range
for just various types of weapons which
was recently recognized by the Ukrainian
Ministers of Defense reznikov who said
that Ukraine has become uh the scene of
a competition of different types of
weapon systems Mr President
we are extremely surprised by the
attempts of Western colleagues
to take credit for the transport of
Russian food and fertilizer through the
world food program the president of
France macron declared that supposedly
the the channels of supplies were uh
were established thanks to the efforts
of France and the world food program
using we using the word we and we
similarly are hearing statements similar
statements from Western statements I'd
like to know who are we who
who I just want to recall that we're
talking about fertilizer that Western
countries retain on their territory and
that Russia proposed to transfer by
itself to developing countries and the
West in particular the European Union
not only did not assist us but but tried
to prevent it now they're trying to
claim all the credit for it I want to
once again stress that it's a Russian
fertilizer that are being sent to Africa
that were earlier uh retained in the
European Union and and Frozen and it was
Russia itself that proposed to deliver
this to developing countries that is
precisely what is taking place with the
mediation of the world food prep program
and we're actually paying for this
ourselves for the transport Mr President
it will be naive to think that all the
assistance provided by the West all the
military and financial support of
Ukraine is used as intended we have
provided quite a bit of evidence how a
significant part of this weapon falls
into the hands of terrorists and
criminals fueling conflict conflicts
around the world whereas a huge amount
of the equipment is simply stolen it
appears that at last the countries that
are supplying the so-called assistance
have begun to give serious thought to
this on the 7th of November a group of
American experts was sent to Ukraine to
verify the supplies of weapons to Kiev
it turns out the United States monitors
just one tenth of the part of those
weapons or 22 000 units the fate of the
rest of the weapons sent is unknown
at the same time as a result the
bankruptcy of a major American
cryptocurrency Exchange FTX and and the
literal disappearance of billions in ass
of assets they're a very entertaining
facts are emerging but the context of
that exchange with the Ukrainian
authorities the founder and owner of
that exchange happens to be one of the
biggest donors of the U.S Democratic
party which is uh playing a key role in
providing assistance the key of
such machinations are no or do not
surprise us but the American taxpayers
might be surprised to learn about them
now there are faint voices of reason
that are beginning to be heard in the
west but they are drowned out by the
core aggressive chorus of those who are
seeking by any means to prolong
hostilities and to inflict and defeat on
Russia with the help of Ukraine
Secretary General of NATO still
staltenberg has stated that the alliance
considers unacceptable any context which
would be aimed at finding a solution
that takes into account the positions
and interests of Russia whereas the
former special representative of the
United States in Ukraine Mr volcker in
his article condition normalizations of
relations between West and Russia with
the defeat change of leadership and
revision of our external borders the
responsibility for their transgressions
Western countries are trying to shift it
on Russia then they're using their
they're using our organization the
United Nations for their sordid ends
this was clearly demonstrated this past
Monday on the 14th of November during
the debates of the special session of
the general assembly this the Western
initiators of a resolution on so-called
reparations could not even provide a
broad outline what kind of mechanism on
compensation of damages to Ukraine they
intend to create instead of that they
force developing countries to Simply
sign on to a legally dubious politicized
text aimed at the illegal legalization
of the expropriation of foreign assets
but this time even Western the Western
campaign of intimidation coercion and
blackmail didn't work the results of the
vote where over half of member states
refused to support a new anti-russian
screed speak for themselves for most
countries including those who you've
forced to vote for this text
for those countries the double standards
of Western colleagues are obvious their
unwillingness to answer for their own
crimes slavery colonialists military
invasions blockades and sanctions
for their attempts to replace
international law with the rules-based
order
in which they themselves Define the
rules the developing World once again
could see for itself that the Ukrainian
crisis is a mere political currency and
the plans of the West an instrument to
punish undesirables for submission of
those who depend on it and to retain
global domination that is slipping away
in the midst of an emerging multi-polar
world thank you very much
I thank the representative of the
Russian Federation for their statement
I shall now make a statement in my
capacity as a representative of Ghana
I thank USG Rosemary DeCarlo for her
comprehensive briefing
an assessment of the security and
humanitarian situations in Ukraine
at the outset area firm Ghana's complete
commitment to the sovereignty
political Independence Center to
Integrity of Ukraine
we reiterate our support for all
legitimate International efforts aimed
at restoring Ukraine to a state of peace
colleagues the question of Global Food
security is critical
during the last meeting of the Council
on Ukraine many delegations showed
strong support for the continuity of the
Black Sea grade initiative
we are pleased that the Russian
Federation has since reconsidered the
suspension of its participation in the
initiative which are so far recorded
more than 10 million metric tons of
grain shipment across the world
the active leadership of the Secretary
General and those of the government of
turkey have been key to the effective
operationalization of the initiative
and we remain supportive of their
efforts in this regard
as the 120-day initiative draws to a
close on 19th November we count on the
good faith commitments of all
stakeholders for the timely renewal of
the grand deal
the almost 100 million people who suffer
from high levels of food insecurity
is an unacceptable reality
where that their conditions should be at
the Forefront of discussions
to ensure unhindered Global Food
Supplies
and the adoption of pragmatic measures
to address impediments to the export of
Russian fertilizers and Agro products we
must prevent the further Western of food
insecurity in the coming months
under the deteriorating security and
humanitarian situations Ghana remains
deeply concerned by the intensified
missile and drone attacks in several
cities of Ukraine
including renewed attacks on Keith High
cave and leave yesterday
they are relented assault on Ukraine's
already battered energy infrastructure
amidst the upcoming winter season
threatened the livelihoods and lives of
many civilians
many home schools and medical facilities
also have no Heating or access to
portable water
typical of all conflict situations
the woman children
and vulnerable persons most of whom are
either displaced or sheltered and
bonkers
have become the worst victims of this
war
the attacks on civilians and civilian
infrastructure review the West form of
our common Humanity
and may constitute serious violations of
international law
it departs from the accepted norms and
the customary principles of conventional
Warfare codified in the Geneva
conventions of 1949 and the additional
protocol relating to the protection of
victims of international armed conflict
Ghana therefore retraces call on the
parties to bring their forces in accord
with international law
including International humanitarian law
and human rights law
we are gravely alarmed by the major
reports of possible war crimes in the
city of hex Esson
and maintain the principal position that
such claims including human rights
violations
and conflict-related sexual violence be
submitted to Torah transparent and
independent investigations
the security Council together of the
International Community must work
collectively to avoid impunity in
Ukraine and secure justice for all
victims of the war
we know to satisfaction the ongoing
humanitarian efforts including the
distribution of cash
food and non-food items medical Outreach
and Water Sanitation and hygiene
services
in commanding the United Nations
humanitarian agencies and partners for
the life-saving support provided since
the beginning of the war
we also stress the need for such efforts
to be guided by the fundamental
principles of humanity neutrality
impartiality and Independence
while working the elevated humanitarian
efforts
redeem it necessary to point out that
humanitarian assistance only offers
temporary leave
and is insufficient to protect civilians
from harm
humanitarian assistance cannot
substitute the requirement for a
comprehensive
and Lasting resolution of the conflict
we therefore reiterate our call on the
Russian Federation to immediately and
unconditionally seize this aggression
against Ukraine consistent with the
rules of international law
and the purposes and principles of the
United Nations chapter
and to seek a resolution of his concerns
through diplomacy and dialogue
yesterday's polish missile incident
and the experience of History reminds us
of the risks that the continuation of
this unnecessary War
poses in its feather spread
the scenes from the city of herxson are
telling signs of how much that people
desire to enter the war and end to the
strife and the beginning of a new
chapter of Peace reconciliation and
reconstruction
the council must therefore support all
efforts for peace I thank you
I resume my function as a president of
the council
I now give the floor to the
representative of Ukraine
well thank you Mr President
distinguished members of the security
Council under Secretary General nicarlo
I think under secretary Rosemarie De
Carlo
for Hill briefing
I'm sure it is difficult
if not painful
to deliver such a tragic account
oh the situation on the ground
I'm also profoundly thankful
to our friend and colleague
U.S permanent representative Ambassador
Linda Thomas Greenfield
for sharing her personal experience
of meeting some of the victims
of Russian war crimes in Ukraine
we believe every member of these Council
ought to visit Ukraine
you are all welcome
all
but Russia
that must immediately leave Ukraine and
stop this Carnage
and stop making a cannon folder
production line of its own people
I also recognize here the representative
of the terrorist Russian regime in the
permanent seat of the Soviet Union
what a mockery of Peace efforts that
terrorists
are still at the table on an equal
footing with 14 members of the security
Council
one day after the gravest attack on
Ukraine's critical infrastructure
while temperatures in Ukraine start
dropping below freezing this terrorists
aim to deprive ukraines of electricity
water
and hitting
more than 90 missiles targeted energy
facilities and other civilian
infrastructure
in and at least 11 regions of Ukraine
as a result about 10 million ukrainians
throughout the country were affected by
emergency blackouts
Ukraine expresses its solidarity
with brotherly Polish people following
yesterday's tragedy in the village of
sevoud
where two people were killed by missiles
we support a full and transparent
investigation to establish all the facts
of this tragic incident
and we are ready to cooperate with the
Polish site to contribute to this
investigation
at the same time it is clear
that the Russian war of aggression
against Ukraine with regular missile
Terror is one of his core elements
Remains the only root cause of violence
and human suffering in Ukraine
and Beyond
as soon as Russia is unable to continue
its War Security in the region will
immediately be restored
now Ukraine defense itself from barbaric
attacks by Russia that aim at aim to
deprive millions of people of access to
their basic needs and thus creating a
humanitarian disaster that could spill
over
far beyond my country
we are grateful for the support of our
friends in particular Poland
encountering these attacks and bringing
peace and security back to our region
Mr President Russia commits its nasty
attacks against civilians because it is
the only kind of Revenge it can take for
its regular military and diplomatic
defeats
last week Ukraine restored its
sovereignty over four and a half
thousand square kilometers in her son
and Nikolai region
Russian forces were kicked out of the
only Regional Center they had been able
to occupy since the beginning of the
invasion
you might have seen the touching
pictures of how the local people who
spend eight months on the occupation
and and you will have a heavy suffering
at the hands of the Russians greeted
their liberators
on the streets of her son and otherly
occupied settlements
eight months ago when the Russian
occupying forces entered her son
its residents were on the streets as
well
the atmosphere was totally different
but there were some similarities with
the joyful rallies in November
the Russian occupiers were also met with
Ukrainian Flags
the Ukrainian anthem
and the slogan her son is Ukraine
it is a matter of sadness that many did
not leave to see
the occupation
fleeing from the right Bank of the
Nipper River the Russian army Left
Behind traces of the same atrocities
that he committed in other regions
investigators have already documented
more than 400 Russian war crimes and the
bodies of both civilians and military
personnel have been found
there is nothing for Russian diplomacy
to boast about either
perhaps accepting the sprinting skills
that Putin's representative regularly
develops by promptly fleeing from this
chamber and I appreciate that he is here
today
Russian diplomacy did not and could not
find any credible argument
in response to the adoption by the
general assembly of the resolution for
furtherance of remedy
and reparation for aggression against
Ukraine
we welcome this adoption which is a
clear message of Hope For Justice and an
important first step towards
accountability
president recently we have heard a
number of statements from the Russian
side on negotiations and dialogue
one can hardly comment on the sincerity
of these statements against the backdrop
of nine dozen missiles shelled on
civilian infrastructure in one day
if there is no concrete action to
restore peace it means that Russia
simply wants to deceive all of us again
Russia wants to buy time build up its
forces and then launch another wave of
aggression Terror and global
destabilization
we must not allow Russia to recharge it
is time to stop the war before the
situation finally spirals in a menacing
Direction unpredictable and uncontrolled
we must not allow Russia
to recharge they said but we also have
to remember what president zielinsky
outlined while addressing the g19 summit
ready radiation and nuclear safety
should be the first to be ensured
Russia must immediately withdraw all
these militants from the territory of
the Zappa regia NPP
the station must be immediately
transferred to the control of the
international atomic energy
agency
and the Ukrainian personnel
second
food security should also be in the
focus
due to the strong participation of the
UN UK and other partners we have been
able to improve full security globally
since July Ukraine has exported over 10
million tons of foodstuffs by sea
in order to increase our expert by
several million tones per month Ukraine
proposes to expand the grain expert
initiative to other ports in particular
the port of mikalaya and olvia in the
mikalai region
Ukraine has also launched the grain from
Ukraine initiative to support the most
vulnerable the first ship with 27 000
tons of wheat leaves to Ethiopia
Ethiopia that continues to vote against
Ukraine nevertheless we ship our grain
to Ethiopia
Ukraine can expert 45 million tones to
foodstuff this year
any country can join and contribute to
ensuring the Ukrainian grain
be supplied to those in need
and let and let a significant part of it
be directed to those who suffer the most
third
is energy security
the Russian Terror against Ukrainian
energy infrastructure aims as well to
prevent the expert of our electricity to
neighboring countries
while Russia is interested in energy
crisis we should all be interested in
ending Terror
I think I think all our partners who
have already helped Ukraine with a
supply of air defense and missile
defense systems
they work but we need more to ensure
full protection from Russian terrorists
we are ready to accept a mission of un
experts
to the objects of critical energy
infrastructure of Ukraine to assess the
scale of damage and the needs for
restoration as well as to prevent their
further destruction
fourth
critical the fourth critical step
is the release of all prisoners and
deportees
thousands of our people military and
civilians are in Russian captivity
they are subjected to brutal torture
Russia also continues to hold at least
11 000 children who have been forcibly
deported to Russia
the only viable solution will be the
release of prisoners on an all-for-all
basis
fifth
the principles of the UN Charter must be
fully respected
Ukraine will not be ready to compromise
the sovereignty and territorial
Integrity within its internationally
recognized borders
six
Russian troops must be withdrawn from
the territory of Ukraine and Ukraine's
control over all sections of our state
border with Russia must be restored
this will result in a real and complete
cessation of hostilities
seventh
Justice should should immediately come
next
everywhere when we liberate our land we
see one thing Russia leaves behind
torture chambers and mass burials of
murdered people
this was the case in Butcher and other
cities in the north of the country after
their occupation this was the case in
the harki region the same we observe now
in the Herson region
eighth is a need to immediately protect
the environment
millions of hectares of forests were
burned by shelling
almost 200 000 hectares to our land are
contaminated with unexploded mines and
shells
dozens of coal mines are flooded
therefore at the climate change
Conference held recently in Egypt
Ukraine proposed to create a platform to
assess the environmental damage of wool
the ninth step is to prevent escalation
Ukraine requires effective security
assurances which should be an integral
element of the post-war security
architecture in the euro-atlantic space
these guarantees could be formalized in
the key of security compact the draft of
this document has been already
elaborated by Ukraine
and the final step will be a
confirmation of the end of the wall when
all the anti-war measures are
implemented when security and Justice
begin to be restored a document
confirming the end of the war should be
signed by the parties
president it seems that since our
meetings in October Russia has leveled
up in defining its enemies in this world
last time as you remember there were
more there were more war mosquitoes
and birds
as we found out recently Russia now
tries a quote
to stop the supreme ruler of hell
whatever the name he uses Satan Lucifer
or Iblis
in these five Russian enemies
are backed by westerners who have I
quote
saliva running down their chins from
degeneracy end of quote
who do you think these quotations belong
to
an inebriated person
a narrow-minded fan of Nazi ideas so
Superior or degenerative Nations
in fact it belongs to the former Russian
president
Mr midve
now Putin's Deputy in the Russian
Security Council
I wonder why the Russian delegation
refrained from delivering this important
update to the council
operas we should prepare for another
urgent council meeting as soon as Russia
finds those who could brief the Council
on how to exercise demons
it would be a logical continuation of
both the Russian attempts to discredit
the security Council and the process of
internal moral degradation of the
Kremlin
unfortunately these morbid Reflections
have led to the deaths of tens of
thousands in the bloodiest war in Europe
since the Second World War
Russia must be stopped
and due to the courage of the Ukrainian
Army
due to the commitment of the Ukrainian
people due to the international
solidarity with Ukraine Russia will be
stopped and I thank you
I thank the representative of Ukraine
for their statement
I gave the floor to the representative
of Poland
Mr President allowed me to start by
providing the members of the security
Council with some additional details
about the yesterday's tragic event in
Poland
on November 15 around at around 3 30 PM
during yet another wave of massive
missile strikes by Russian forces
against civilian critical infrastructure
in the whole of Ukraine
including the immediate vicinity of the
territory of Poland
to public citizens lost their lives in
the Polish Village of trevodov situated
around the five kilometers from the
Polish Ukrainian border
the apparent K cause of their death was
the explosion from the missile that fell
on the location
which has no military background
whatsoever
it would like to I would like to express
our deepest gratitude for the gestures
of solidarity also heard today
that Poland keeps receiving from all
over the world with regards to this
tragic event
no matter what was the particular cause
of the course of the events in chevodov
the fact that that fight the afternoon
those innocent people would not have
been killed if there had been no Russian
war against Ukraine
the only fault was their only thought
was the fact that they lived close to
the civilian infrastructure on the
Ukrainian side of the Border that Russia
keeps attacking as a military targets
Mr President yesterday's sad events
teaches us how close we actually live to
a potential escalation and the spillover
of the Russian war against the against
war of aggression of far-reaching
consequences that we all can foresee
bearing that in mind
Poland decided to act with full
restraint and responsibility
we immediately launched an extensive
multi-faced investigation aimed at
explaining all the details of the
incident
the very initial findings support the
hypothesis that the event was not a
deliberate attack
but naturally we need to wait for the
final conclusion until the until the
investigation is over
Poland is also conducting the Intensive
consultations on the incident with its
NATO allies and the key partners
a decision had to be also be made to
increase the combat Readiness of the
selected units of the Polish Armed
Forces with particular emphasis on
airspace monitoring
we wish to assure the whole
International Community about the
transparency of the ongoing
investigation and about the guarantees
of collective security which Poland will
keep providing to the region both as an
individual country as an and as a part
of the NATO which Remains the defensive
Alliance
we understand our responsibilities
in in that lies in the and that's why
Poland is and will remain original
Stronghold of Peace security and
stability
Mr President
it is clear that is the Russia which is
to blame for menacing the word with the
with the war of aggression and its
spillover effects including the
yesterday's tragic incident in Poland
the launching of yesterday's missile
attacks against Ukraine the fiercest
since the beginning of the war requires
significant military preparations
despite recent setbacks on the
battlefield Moscow clearly did not
change its goals it still wants to erase
Sovereign Ukraine from the map and the
costs innocent people to suffer
this evidently shows Russia's absolute
lack of will to embark on the path of
leading to on the Republic leading to a
resolution of the conflict that it has
created
Russia pretends to be ready for talks
but in reality it's carrying our its
barbaric attacks against the civilian
population and energy infrastructure of
Ukraine
distinguished member of the security
Council the current situation will not
change our approach Poland believes it
is crucial to continue the support for
Ukraine
Poland has done so since the very
beginning of the war
we approach it in the multi-dimensional
way by providing Aid buff for in Ukraine
as well as within our own territory
we'll continue on this path
total estimated value of the Polish Aid
given to in 2022 to Ukrainian refugees
both by individuals as well as the local
and state authorities amounts to over
5.5 billion dollars silica one percent
of the Polish GDP
according to the OCD estimates in 2022
Poland will spend for humanitarian and
Military assistance the total of 8.5
billion dollars it's almost 0.1.5
percent of the Polish GDP becoming one
of the major donors to Ukraine
as we heard today currently the most
urgent humanitarian issue that we need
to focus is on the upcoming winter
due to the Russian bombings over 3.5
million people are left without the roof
over their head the priority is to
create shelter for those people
the Russian forces continuously attacked
the Ukrainian energy infrastructure and
then the deliberate attempt to aggravate
the humanitarian crisis the goal is
probably also to cause another wave of
refugees which is calculated to
destabilize the situation in the
countries to which they arrive including
Poland
Mr President Russian imperialism needs
to be treated as as the thing it really
is a global threat with far-reaching
consequences
This Global threat needs to be
neutralized before it plunges into the
the whole world further into cows
this word needs to end with a just piece
the just peace it needs to end on terms
which are acceptable for Ukraine
the aggressor cannot benefit from the
from its aggression instead we need
accountability for what atrocities and
damages it is inflicted therefore Poland
welcomes the last week's General
Assembly resolution of the creation of
the registry of Damages mechanism we see
that the first step in the right
direction
in conclusion we once again called on
the all states which stands on the side
of international law to make to take all
necessary steps to persuade Russia to
stop its aggression and to withdraw from
Ukrainian territory it is the only way
to prevent further deaths injuries and
devastations this is the only way to
stop escalation of this large-scale
humanitarian and human rights crisis
that continues to bring away lives of
innocent civilians and I think
I thank the representative of Poland for
the statement I give the floor to the
representative of Estonia
Mr President distinguished members of
council
I'm speaking on behalf of free Baltic
states Latvia Lithuania and my own
country Estonia
we thank the under Secretary General
Rosemead de Carla for her most valuable
briefing
allow me to start by commending the
immense bravery of the Ukrainian Defense
Forces that last Friday after months of
Russian occupation
took back control of kerson
there is no doubt that sooner or later
Ukraine will liberate all the occupied
territories within its International
recognized borders
this territories are Ukraine and Ukraine
has every right to defend them in full
accordance with article 51 of the
charter
we are steadfast in supporting Ukraine's
efforts for as long as it takes and will
continue providing strong political
military and financial support to
Ukraine
Russian missiles hitting critical
infrastructure and residential buildings
in Kiev and in a number of other
Ukrainian cities yesterday once again
prove that Russia is not interested in
peace
during the heaviest wave of missile
strikes against Ukraine since February
two polish citizens lost their lives in
an explosion that took place in the east
of Poland
allow me to extend my deepest
condolences to the families of all those
who lost tragically their lives due to
this barbaric attack
notwithstanding ongoing investigations
it is clear that Russia alone Bears the
responsibility for the explosion as it
continues its legal war against Ukraine
we commend the Swift actions by the U.N
humanitarian agencies led by the
humanitarian coordinator Dennis Brown to
bring humanitarian Aid to her son on
Monday for the first time since the
Russian forces took control of her son
as in other liberated areas the Russian
army left her son with the trail of
atrocity crimes
the city was left without water heat
electricity and Communications we urge
Russia to give access to humanitarian
organizations to areas currently under
their occupation so that necessary
emergency assistance can reach all those
in need in Ukraine
the winter is approaching fast in
Ukraine with the temperatures expected
to fall well below freezing point
by using missiles and Iranian Supply
drones Russia's deliberate strikes
against Ukraine's energy facilities have
left by now 7 million people without
electricity and Lithuania are continuing
to provide humanitarian Aid to Ukraine
to address the needs worsened by the
winter and Russia's Russian attacks
against Ukrainian infrastructure as well
as the mining assistance
we also urge Russia to give access to
the U.N representatives and the icrc to
the places of Detention of civilians and
prisoners of war and ensure access of a
U.N fact-finding mission to a lenifka
the deportation of Ukrainian children
to Russia is a war crime
children belong to their families and
loved ones and they must be safely and
immediately returned to their homes Mr
President
the Russian are provoked and brutal war
of aggression against Ukraine has
triggered issues of deep Global concern
due to Russia's blockade of Ukrainian
seaports and the destruction of
necessary infrastructure Russia has
caused a global food crisis and
essentially weaponized food and hunger
as mean of as means of hybrid Warfare
the Black Sea grain initiative alongside
the Euless solidarity Lanes has
therefore Been instrumental in
stabilizing the global food market and
providing food to millions of people in
Africa Asia and Europe
Russia's statements claiming that
Ukrainian grain is reaching only
European countries
and that its own grain and fertilizers
shipments are prohibited by Western
sanctions are fake as we have heard the
U.N officials are test also in Wisconsin
we praise the U.N Secretary General and
turkey for all the efforts to renew the
grain deal and we urge Russia to agree
to the renewal of initiative Beyond
November 19 and implemented in good
faith
we strongly condemn Russia's
irresponsible nuclear rhetoric and its
cynical accusations against Ukraine of
creating a dirty bomb these accusations
have been clearly and unequivocally
refuted by the international atomic
energy agency
we urge Russia to immediately withdraw
all of its troops and military equipment
from the premises of the Borussia
nuclear power plant that Russia
illegally controls
and stop its nuclear blackmail
finally
it is critical that all evidence of
crimes and violations of human rights
and international humanitarian law
committed in Ukraine
continue to be gathered
in a manner that will hold up in
independent impartial judicial
institutions
we are determined to ensure that all
those responsible for war or other
atrocity crimes must be held to account
but as has been said the most
responsible people are those who decided
to wage this illegal war against Ukraine
the aggressor cannot go unpunished or
ours will follow its lead
we therefore call for establishing a
special tribunal to fill the current
jurisdictional loophole and bring the
Russia's top political and Military
leadership to justice for committed for
committing the crime of aggression
against Ukraine I thank you
I thank the representative of Estonia
for their statement
I now give the floor to his Excellency
Mr Olive Scott
head of the delegation of the European
Union to the United Nations
thank you very much Mr President for
convening us and thank you for the
opportunity to address the council this
afternoon and thank you to Rosemary
DeCarlo for a very comprehensive
briefing
I have the honor to speak on behalf of
the European Union and its member states
and I would like to highlight the
following three points one the
importance of upholding International
humanitarian law secondly on
accountability for crimes committed in
Ukraine and thirdly on the global
consequences of Russia's war of
aggression first Mr President on
International humanitarian law during
the past weeks Russia has stepped up its
targeted strikes against Ukraine
civilians and civilian infrastructure
yesterday saw the largest and gravest
missile attacks since the start of the
invasion
we express our condolences to the
families of the victims in both Ukraine
and in Poland
by deliberately disrupting energy and
water supply Russia is trying to
paralyze Ukraine and saw despair within
the population as winter approaches
these unacceptable actions targeting
civilians and civilian infrastructure by
Russia are unlawful and they constitute
war crimes
the IMF estimates that Ukraine may need
four billion dollars a month just to
keep the lights on and the Taps running
we cannot leave the Ukrainian people in
such a situation the EU is there for
undertaking urgent Rehabilitation
measures to prepare for winter and
repair the energy infrastructure bombed
by Russia
we are also working on a package to
ensure Ukraine's macroeconomic stability
maintaining essential public services
and rebuild critical infrastructure
I also reiterate the need for full
humanitarian access including in areas
not currently under the Ukrainian
government's control
my second Point Mr chairman concerns
accountability the images from the
liberation of Kirsten bring both Joy and
Dread
joy as the population welcomed its
liberators after eight months of brutal
occupation dread a story stories and
evidence of Cruelty and war crimes
surface as they did in Butcher easium
and elsewhere it is a Paramount
importance to continue documenting all
evidence of war crimes committed
throughout Ukraine rely on the
international criminal court and on the
Ukrainian authorities to bring
perpetrators to account
we acknowledge Ukraine's efforts to
secure accountability including for the
crime of aggression we're accordingly
examining the feasibility of various
options in order to see how full
accountability can be insured in an
optimal way
Monday's resolution by the general
assembly to recommend the creation of a
register of Damages and recognizing the
need for reparation of damage is another
important step to ensure accountability
all victims of Russia's aggression
deserve justice and reparation the EU
will continue to support Ukraine in the
framework of the icj proceedings and we
also highlight the important work of the
commission of inquiry established by the
Human Rights Council in this regard
thirdly Mr President on the global
consequences
by weaponizing food in its war against
Ukraine Russia is solely responsible for
the escalating Global Food security
crisis the EU is at the Forefront of
global efforts to address food
insecurity which is affecting millions
of vulnerable people especially in
developing countries
we reiterate our strong support to all
efforts to extend the U.N broken Black
Sea grain initiative and to scale up
operations for the delivery of much
needed grain and other foodstuffs we
commend the work of the U.N sector
General and the joint coordination
Center in Istanbul in this regard
according to un data two-thirds of the
wheat exported from Ukraine through the
Black Sea grain initiative has gone to
developing countries
in addition to export oversea through
the EU Ukraine solidarity Lanes 15
million tons of Agriculture Goods have
been exported from Ukraine to Global
markets over land
to address capacity constraints and
further facilitate export from Ukraine
the EU has mobilized an additional 250
million euros
in parallel the e was stepping up Global
food assistance earlier this week a new
humanitarian 8-pack package of 210
million euros for 15 countries was
announced bringing the eu's overall food
security support up to 8 billion euros
between 2021 and 2024.
we call on others to follow suit and
step up their humanitarian assistance to
the most vulnerable two and I wanted to
express here my appreciation and of the
solidarity and some very good
humanitarian Justice that have been
announced by several members of this
Council including some from very far
away
Mr President
zelenski stated earlier this week that
his country is ready for peace
the EU supports all genuine and
meaningful efforts to this end in full
respect of international law including
Ukraine sovereignty and territorial
Integrity we note however that Russia
has not shown any indications it is
engaging in serious and sincere
diplomatic efforts on the contrary it
has stepped up its missile attacks on
civilian infrastructure
the E will continue to stand by Ukraine
for as long as it takes and we continue
to urge Russia to immediately cease all
hostilities and unconditionally withdraw
all its forces and military equipment
from the entire territory of Ukraine
within within its International
recognized borders the war would end
tomorrow if Russia withdraws as
requested by the general assembly
thank you very much Mr President
I thank his Excellency Mr skok for his
statement
and now give the floor to the
representative of Slovakia
thank you Mr President
Slovakia aligns itself with the
statement delivered by the distinguished
representatives of the European Union Mr
President
we are approaching nine months since the
beginning of the unprovoked and
unjustified Russian military aggression
against Ukraine in violations of all
fundamental values and principles of the
U.N Charter and international law
despite many calls of the International
Community the Russian Federation remains
silent and continues to justify its
so-called special military operation and
the false pretext based on spreading
this information and propaganda which we
strongly condemned
how can the Russian Federation continue
to persuade us that its action is
justifiable under international law
we have heard in last month In This Very
Room
from the Russian Representatives have
Ukrainian civilians were happy to see
the Russian army allegedly liberating
them from the Kiev influence
but recent pictures and videos of
civilians greeting Ukrainian brave
soldiers fighting for the future of
their country with open arms in the
newly liberated city of Harrison proved
the exod opposite
and only confirm that the Russian
Federation has tried to persuade us
about its Kingdom of crooked mirrors
perception
Slovakia remains to be Gravely concerned
about the humanitarian situation in
Ukraine which unfortunately
progressively further deteriorates
we remain upheld by the huge numbers of
killings of innocent civilians attacks
on critical infrastructure as well as
the huge scale of sexual and
gender-based violence committed by
Russian soldiers and occupants
we deplore in the strongest terms
yesterday's Russian missile attacks
across Ukraine plunging 7 million homes
Into Darkness
Mr President
how can we expect that the Russian
Federation adheres to the international
law humanitarian law including and
protects in innocent civilians in time
of War when it ignores to guarantee
fundamental rights of its own citizens
we were horrified by the video with the
execution of a former Russian Prison
inmate by a sledgehammer
such an action is nothing else but
arbitrary killing and multiple violation
of Human Rights including the right to
life and the proof that the human rights
are for the Russian Federation nothing
but a concept which it is deliberately
ignoring
Mr President
we would also like to reiterate our
concerns over the serious effects of the
Russian invasion on Global Food security
as a result millions of people around
the world are being pushed into extreme
poverty hunger and lack of access to
food
as the Black Sea grain initiative is
about to expire we strongly support its
extension
last but not least
Slovakia urges the Russian Federation to
listen finally to the voice of the
United Nations
and Implement Implement all respective
resolutions including the resolution of
the general assembly adopted this Monday
I thank you
I thank the representative of Slovakia
for their statement
there are no more names inscribed on the
list of speakers the meeting is
adjourned
foreign
okay